Tomorrow is International Day Against Homophobia,
Transphobia and biphobia, a day to stand against bigotry
and hate against the 2S LGBTQIA community.
This year has been a difficult one for our Manitoba
2 s LGBTQIA relatives.
Family friendly
drag queen story time was targeted by aggressive counter protesters.
Proposed book bands in Brandon
are threatened to erase queer families from school libraries.
National organization pushed misinformation
events like the Million March for kids in cities across Canada,
including here in Winnipeg.
The former PC government not only tolerated this hate,
they encouraged it. Heather Stephenson
broke her promise to walk alongside the 2S LGBTQIA Manitobans
and use her first pride as premiere for a photo op.
Members opposite
tried to create a narrative about the member for Kirkfield Park
that he was a danger to children
when he ran to become the first trans man
elected to the Manitoba Legislative Assembly.
The member for Fort White
repeatedly called community concerns about book bands
fear mongering
while at the same time he was the face of fear mongering ads
endangering two ass LGBTQI youth.
For years, the member for borderland has routinely refused to clap
or stand for two s LGBTQIA Manitobans
honored in this very chamber
order.
Their federal leader Pierre Poliov
continues to spread disinformation
and ally himself with people who want to harm the two US
LGBTQI community.
And that entire side of the house made targeting transgender kids
a core part of their failed election campaign.
Who targets Children, each and every one of them.
But Manitobans have shown there is no order,
order,
order.
You may not like what you hear,
but I expect respect in this chamber.
The honorable minister of families,
we go at your honorable speaker.
But Manitobans have shown
there is no space for hate in our beautiful province.
Mənə çovğun.
Manitobans showed up with signs at school board meetings
and drag queen story times.
They attended Brandon school board meetings in the hundreds.
Thousands of people even gathered on the steps of this very building
to stand up against homophobic,
transphobic, so called parental rights movement.
Fighting hate and fear with love and joy and support.
And when this former cold
and callous PC government spoke at last year's Winnipeg Pride parade,
Manitobans turned their backs on them and rejected their hate,
discrimination and division.
Manitobans have shown we believe in a better future together.
To our 2S LGBTQIA relatives, no,
we continue and will always stand with you
and will always fight against anyone who tries to target, devalue,
bully or harm you. That includes holding members opposite
accountable for what their failed PC government tried to do to you.
So when the member opposite gets up to speak in a couple of seconds,
don't believe what they tell you,
believe what they show you and continue to show you.
Because today
the only thing they should be doing is getting up in the house
and apologizing.